[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developers news
from Google in the last week.
The next maintenance
release for Android Nougat
is just around the corner,
and the public beta
is now available to eligible
devices that have enrolled
in the Android Beta Program.
For more info and to sign
up, head on over to the post
linked in the description below.
"The Guardian" was able
to substantially increase
user engagement
with its mobile app
during the recent
US election by using
new notifications functionality
available in the Android 7.0
Nougat.
The engagement results
were impressive,
including a 103% increase
in daily installs
during an election week.
Check out how they
did it on the post.
In our continuous quest to
discover, nurture growth,
and showcase the best
games from Indonesia,
we are happy to announce
the Indonesia Games Contest.
Submit your game by
March 19 of this year.
Details are on the post.
We are open-sourcing
Google Earth Enterprise,
the Enterprise
product that allows
developers to build and host
their own private maps and 3D
globes.
Google Earth Enterprise Fusion,
Server, and Portable Server
source code will be published
on GitHub under the Apache 2
License in March.
We've recently
published new guidelines
to help data providers
describe their data
sets in a structured way,
enabling Google and others
to link this structured metadata
with information describing
locations, scientific
publications,
or even Knowledge
Graph, facilitating
data discovery for others.
We hope that this
metadata will help
us improve the discovery and
reuse of public data sets
on the web for everybody.
If you're a data provider,
data consumer, or a developer,
please check out this post.
The Firebase Test Lab
team is kicking off 2017
with some new features
that make it easier
for you to customize the
testing of your Android apps.
Check out their posts for
details on enhancements
that are designed to save
you time and money so you
can get the most out of Test Lab
for your daily testing routine.
We recently launched the
beta version of Cloud Tools
for Eclipse, a plugin that
extends Eclipse to Google Cloud
Platform.
Based on Google Cloud SDK,
the initial feature set
targets App Engine
standard environment,
including support for
creating applications, running
and debugging them inside the
IDE with the Eclipse Web Tools
platform tooling, and
deploying them to production.
To get started, check out the
post linked in the description
below.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
For some of our past
episodes, click here or here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]